pretty much all reputable sources says
there's no link there is no evidence
that the use of antiperspirants
increases your risk for breast cancer
there is no link between aluminum and
breast cancer risk there are no strong
epidemiologic studies in the medical
literature that link breast cancer risk
and antiperspirant use and very little
scientific evidence to support this
claim there is no good evidence that
aluminum in deodorants could increase
the risk of cancer in animals or humans
no scientific evidence links the use of
these products to the development of
breast cancer no studies to date have
confirmed any substantial adverse
effects of aluminum that could
contribute to increased breast cancer
risks in late 2019 the European
commission's scientific committee on
consumer safety reevaluated aluminum in
antiperspirants and again they concluded
that they were safe in the amounts used
in cosmetics